so each time it swaps a pair of elements
it plays a sound of both of them you can
you can hear this or fluctuating pitches
each time it compares each pair of
elements it plays a noise and then
potentially Aslaksen what we thought
we'd do is make them all sort hundred
elements and we'll see them side-by-side
in the last couple of videos we've done
on sorting algorithms there's been quite
a few comments on the videos and
requests from people to do some more on
different sorting algorithms so it's
been a couple of weeks since we did the
videos and also there's been some more
videos on computer file in particular I
saw the one on the BBC micro so the BBC
wanted to develop a project to introduce
people to computers and programming they
commissioned the British company called
acorn to make this computer and how easy
it is to use basic to draw things on the
screen and make noises this isn't a
5,000 which is a computer made by acorn
which dates from about 1991 I think so
it's kind of a descendant of the BBC
micro it's got an ARM chip which the BBC
micro didn't have because it's an acorn
it's got its got BBC basic interpreter
built into it there is a BBC basic
interpreter for Windows it's a bit
limited in terms of what you can use for
memory and I didn't have to pay for it
and have this sitting a corner like the
BBC micro the operating system is in ROM
so you turn it on and it's it's pretty
quick to boot up so we just wait
there we go it's booted up unlike the
BBC micro this picks up into a GUI
you've got a mouse and something to
click on this has got the icon bar at
the bottom here and this is a hard drive
icon so you click on that it opens
becomes it's a hard drive in a window
they look familiar to you probably used
any one operating system this is the
floppy drive here so you click on that
ill say drive home see whose it is and
then we've got apps which are some
built-in applications and networking
over here we've got graphics options and
operating system options so acorn we're
talking about apps back in the 90s
well yeah it's just straw applications
so if you click on it
you've got some built-in basic things
he's got an alarm which tells you the
time if you click on configure it brings
up the configuration so you can change
things like sound options so I can
change the noise to be various different
things when I was looking at sorting
algorithms on YouTube I found another
video or another couple videos made by
someone else who had written a program
in C++ but did a visualization of
sorting algorithms so it would show you
an unsorted list and it would sort into
water each time it would swap a pair of
elements or do something it would play a
certain pitch depending on the value of
that element well that's quite
interesting but there are some sorting
algorithms that they haven't done I'd
like to see so I thought I'd do it
myself
they posted their source code and it was
using some C++ library that I couldn't
get up-to-date version of in my system
so a library is just a collection of of
code written by other people that does a
certain task for you so you can just use
that mostly we use libraries of code
because you can generally be guaranteed
that it does what it's supposed to do
correctly and I thought well having seen
that BBC basic video and the the
triangles program on-screen I can show
you you know I did my own implantation
as well as playing the triangle screen I
also decided to make it make a noise so
I can show you the source code for that
this is it I'm gonna put some spaces in
just make it a little bit
Moe 27 tells it what screen resolution
to use and what colors available that
sort of thing okay and then we've got
this repeat until false block wait does
it repeats all this until false are now
false never evaluated to true so it just
repeats it forever
this says set a variable called color to
a random numbers between 0 and 7 this
then says set the graphics color to that
random number between 0 & 7 then we play
a sound related to that random number as
well so the numbers between 0 & 7 we
need to scale it to be in the range 0 to
that's the pitch value in it 0 is the
lowest pitch it doesn't 2 5 5 is the
highest pitch it will do if we left it 0
to 7 it would just be very low and
they'd all sound quite similar this line
that says plot actually draw the
triangle so that's what you would have
seen in the other video now this line is
here to slow it down because it goes
very fast on this so if I comment this
line out we use REM which I think starts
a reminder so if I save that and then I
run triangles again it goes so fast that
you can't hear any sound because as soon
as it starts playing one sound it's to
try to stop playing the next and you
can't hear anything
another thing I used was a book that
came into my possession I came to the
office called games for your BBC micro
this is just code listings of certain
games the first one I did was quite
short it's called doctor audio it says
this game was a variation of dr. Watson
in which when you guess the computer's
number the feedback is given as a tone
the picture this note there is according
to how far your guesses from the correct
number the sounds are programmed in line
130 this is where how I learned how to
do sounds because it said line hundred
30 sound 1 minus 15 ABS a minus B 5 so
it turns out but I'll have to look this
up because it wasn't in this book sounds
takes 1 2 3 4 different parameters so
the first one is the channel you want to
play on I think channel 0 does
percussion sounds or something strange
so now the first argument says play on
channel 1 the second one is the volume
and that has to be between I think 0 and
minus 15 minus 15 is the loudest 0 is a
quietest
this says ABS a minus B so that
subtracts one number from the other
gets even absolute value of it and then
the last one is the duration of the note
it's in 70 seconds so it's five
hundredths of a second it plays it for
he goes the program they might have rude
words in it I can't remember so so I am
thinking attempt of sleep 100 what is it
let's go for 25 okay it was changed a
little bit from what you said in the
book but IV wrote it so the higher the
pitches the closer it is 25 is wrong you
so what's my next guess I'm going
to say 75
so 75 sounds closer let's try 80 no
that's that's further away 60 yeah I'm
gonna go for 70
arrey where was the disk then with that
book hmm where there's a disk the disk
is the data is stored on the pages which
means you've got to transfer it by your
hands and the keyboard so show me what
that man okay so what I had to do is
type everything in to a nice text editor
this one is not particularly nice this
is the code that does that program this
is about 30 lines probably now I kind of
was a little bit more familiar with BBC
basic and how to draw things and certain
colors and how to play sounds I decided
but I could probably implement those
visual sorting programs so first of all
we've got bubble sort
I think this sorts 30 elements so with
bubble sort we compare elements and keep
swapping elements if they're bigger than
the ones or until they get to the end so
the gray elements are ones that are in
the right place red elements unsorted
and the blue ones are ones they're being
wonder active at the moment so for 30
elements that took twenty-three point
three eight seconds 384 comparisons and
228 swaps so if we change it to 60
elements open it in the editor and
change max file from 32 to 60 so it's a
fact
okay so now we've got 60 elements we've
doubled the input size because it run to
the square of the input size two times
two is four so it should take four times
longer with four times the number of
comparisons and four times a number of
swaps each time it does a comparison and
each time here's a swap it in comes a
counter and just print it out up here
so each time it swaps a pair of elements
it plays a sound of both of them you can
you can hear this all fluctuating
pitches each time it compares each pair
of elements it plays a noise and then
potentially slots number getting smaller
now we're an exciting side 20 maybe now
what this is showing us is each of these
columns which is the same width is a
different number and so that's a low
number and then you've got a high number
so when we start out the list is
unsorted so you've got solved high and
low columns all next to each other and
when we have sorted the list in a bit
low numbers that I ended high numbers at
that end we also covered quicksort in
our previous videos so I'll show you
that so there's a variable called number
of elements set to a thousand so I'm
going to produce it to say 400 okay and
we've also got another option here so we
can set graphical to draw Falls actually
what you find is if you really want to
do proper speed test you need to turn
the graphics off because they slow it
down a lot II wanted to prove a point
and doing something like this by the way
this graph is linked to from the
previous salting videos so let's save
that and then run it so we've got a
quick sort so here's our list of
unsourced element seating there's all
sort of high low ones hopefully you'll
remember from the video on quicksort the
way this works it partitions the list by
picking an element called a pivot and
putting all elements less on it on one
side and greater than on the other side
and then it it does that again a neat
some on each side so you can see it's
kind of it's done all the left-hand side
and now it will start doing the
right-hand side so there's the pivot it
does all the left-hand side it's another
play that keeps doing that until it's
sorted you can see with quicksort it is
a lot quicker than bubble sort another
algorithm that we didn't cover before if
it is still fairly simple is called
selection sort you go through your list
and you look for the lowest element
that's in the unsorted list you take
that and you put it in your sorted list
you go through the unsorted list pick
the lowest element from there put that
in your sorted list here's a hundred
elements being selection sorted we've
got to look through the whole list to
find the smallest and then we put it at
the other end so this is not
particularly quick this also is N
squared because you've got to look at
look at these over and over again it's
the same time complexity as bubblesort
although I think it might perform a
little bit better because it does
slightly fewer comparisons where's there
selling this fewer swaps
yeah only needs to do at most one swap
per element in the list whereas bubble
Sultan go crazy the comparisons are
still quite high and that makes it a
little bit slow what we thought we'd do
is make them all sort hundred elements
and you can see them side by side and
hopefully sped off a bit because some
were quite slow what we've seen is
bubble slaw and cocktail sort and
selection sort of quite slow in
capacitor quicksort quicksort runs in n
log n as we said in the quicksort video
another algorithm that people were
asking about in the comments is heap
sort that also runs an n log n you need
quite a lot of background knowledge to
understand how it works
so heap sort uses something called a
heap now a heap is a type of data
structure which is represented by a
binary tree whereby every element in the
tree has children who were smaller than
it we haven't covered trees to cover
trees need to probably cover linked
lists to cover linked lists we need to
do something about data structures and
we haven't got there yet however I will
show you heap sort before I start it
what it does it builds a heap up the
largest element is always 0 and then it
swaps the elements to at the end and it
restructures the heap so that the
largest elements again at the end
well what list let's go
so this is building up the heat now it's
built the heat it can take you keep
taking the largest element and maintain
the heap structure and producing sort of
risk that was quite quick that was under
elements so it's the same as the other
ones we've just seen if you know where
heap is and not it's different from the
heap the heap is an area of memory as
opposed to the stack but the heap and a
heap not same thing
he's not concerned with the internet
he's not also me getting something does
until we can see the list and then we
say which is lowest between seven and
eight it's seven which is lowest between
eight nothing it's eight and then
similarly with ten and nothing it's ten
it's an idea that we've got in the case
of ipv4